in our research we found that humans go
through a period of change right around
the age of puberty wow you guys are
really doing some groundbreaking work
here aren't you
first they start being rude and
sarcastic then they try to fit in by
giving up the very quirks and interests
that make them who they are next thing
you know they're all just dreamless
husks stumbling blind toward the grave
like a bunch of sad lonely ghosts Jesus
look what would have happened to your
favorite cultural heroes if they'd given
up on their dreams you ever heard of 3d
Drake we started from the bottom now
we're here which is very alarming I
might have got the sixth man there's
more hello hi yes and I'm calling to see
if you are satisfied with your current
auto insurance policy please just turn
that off come on stop it